on this episode we talk Starbucks cups
what'd you do after you got an idea at
me changing my mind
[Music]
[Music]
this
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 161 of the
askgaryvee show India is here huge
controversy that you like weren't there
the last episode people people are
really sad we're outside of Columbus
Circle filming the show Thursday Jets
game Bills of people want to be on the
show photo bombing photo bombing on a
early Thursday morning New York City
official Jets prediction coming up I'm
going to that I'm wearing my uh look at
this wait I don't wanna get wet
my Jets my Jets yikes and we'll get to
that at the end of the show but India
let's get into the show
bang let's do it focused feeling fresh
out of 23 our day yesterday
in Miami then food Orlando them flew to
New York
3:30 a.m. wake-up calls today no
yesterday good mollen asked how do you
structure a 2015 resume to stand out and
sell yourself would you make a video 25
so I'm not a big fan of resumes I I
think interestingly enough if you're
required to use a resume to create your
opportunity you've lost I think I think
2016 resume is networking I think a way
better way to get a job is to create
relationships
I would I would start tweeting act 10 to
20 tastemakers influencers important
executives within the industry you want
to get a job in PR I would follow 40 to
70 major PR executives top 3 PR
executives at Edelman hunter PR you know
those kind of things
Weber shanwick I would follow what they
would say I would interact with them I
would I would request for a five-minute
coffee one and every 60 of them would
say yes networking is the new resume if
you're relying on a piece of paper or a
cheeky video to break through that means
that you have no leverage before you've
walked into the room leverage when you
walk into the room on the on the
interview is the key have being hired
before you walk in is the key and I
think there's a huge opportunity to do
that I mean there's a there's an
unbelievable phenomenon going on on
Twitter which is that you can literally
get to anybody and there's a some
percentage of chance that they'll
actually want to engage with you so the
2016 resume is the networking fool Jusuf
on is the networking that you do before
you walk into the building
yeah it's hi guy likes that Tyler you
know what Adrian this isn't Tyler rarely
on the show never on the show
doing a little scoping
all right periscope aj8 permit each a
different eyes boss aj asks when giving
100 how do you not take your feet
personally when you're giving a hundred
respect step on give me a hundred
Mogi right here because you know I love
that look see what you do with that when
giving 100 percent how is it possible to
not take the feet personally
no meaning like I always take defeat
personally like if I always give a
hundred percent but like when giving a
hundred and ten percent like defeat
should be personal if you do not take
defeat personally then you're a non
winning player but like sorry to get
like very realistic here this morning if
you are not pissed every single time you
lose and I mean Parcheesi
I mean Madden I mean and work I mean
when you don't even control the outcome
aka what I'm gonna deal with it what if
and when the Jets lose tonight when
something I can't even control because
I'm gonna give a hundred as a fan I'm
gonna start fighting and being nasty for
the Bills fans that I see on the way out
I want to get nasty I want to make them
uncomfortable and I take it extremely
personal I really believe that
struggling with defeat being a sore
loser it's an absolute proxy to success
it means you care and when you care you
fight the reason I think I will always
be great at business is I'd literally
want to die instead of fail die death
over I do not know how to live in life I
do not know how to live in life live in
life with an L in business on my resume
it's just yeah I may have Micro elves
but the ultimate L you know that joke I
make of like secretly I want to lose
everything to rise like a phoenix you
know I don't even know yes but boy I'm
not even sure me to get that chance
because I wouldn't even know how to
function society with that loss that's
how much I care and so you should take
defeat personally period
Jared asks do you think Starbucks knew
their customers would overreact to the
design of their new cup and did it just
for marketing the Starbucks cups and I
see Dunkin Donuts came out with their
isms like yeah yeah I thank God it's
holiday uh I think this was interesting
it just speaks to the world we now live
in I mean first of all Starbucks should
be very happy that people give a crap I
mean if you're told Howard Schultz
thirty years ago one day there will be a
national uproar or at least a micro
national uproar
to the cups that you have like that is
like I hope one day that the entire
world or at least the US market is it an
uproar on the subtle aspect of what's
going on in might and I mean the subtle
subtle subtle get down here with me
Stefan
the subtle subtle subtle subtle list of
things that have to do with my business
that people have that much passion
little quick sidenote on this I find it
interesting that everybody's panting a
lot of my friends panties are in a bunch
I saw on social over this cup the same
homies that love the simplistic design
of Apple you know all these told me that
love love simplistic design right yeah
muffin yes love I think it is awesome
love simplistic design and Apple but
here comes the simplistic design in your
coffee cup and it's not holiday enough
people just want to complain people love
to complain you love to complain
complaining is easy complaining is easy
people love to complain how about
executing how about have I been a
complaining trying to build a business
that actually has people complain about
it go do that yeah
pang did you catch that kid or not that
how you did you caught him he was
awesome
you caught us yeah what do you do are
you like focused yeah alright oh oh this
kid yeah by the way this is insane last
week top you were with us oh no you
weren't there you heard about this last
week we're walking into the Jets game
and we see this band playing and we like
with the Jets have a thing called the
Aviators who everybody hates them me
they're like the band that I love them
because mainly they piss off everybody
else of my crew we see these kids and
Mike fly goes not the Aviators I'm gonna
make a joke that it uh and then this
comes through this kid was part of that
band there so it's
see what's going on here sorry you
forgot me
hey what's going on here hey Gary my
name is Nick Sowden and we're about to
perform at MetLife Stadium with the
marching band my question to you is if
you have a great idea for a business or
a product what's the next step you
should take well I think a great
question uh yes I saw him for yeah
that's right there was a little bit of
that yesterday followed up I said yeah
we got you because we already had you
and then everybody was like oh is that
how you get on the show and all this
stuff so anyway um which I think I think
it's very simple the next step is to go
and do it like everybody like you and
all your band mates all of you got good
ideas everybody here's got a guy that
got a good idea like she's got a great
idea she's got everybody everybody's got
ideas what you do next is you make it
happen
maybe you quit band and you go make it
happen maybe you go ask money from your
uncle Milton and that's how you make it
happen I don't know maybe you find a
partner that can build your app you go
to meetups you've got to make it happen
I don't know if that's money that's time
that's a partner that can actually build
out what you need but the answer always
youngster is go and make it happen the
ideas the thoughts are nice I always say
ideas are [ __ ] executions a game I say
that on purpose I'm actually to use this
video as a class a clarification
Stephane cut this out because I'm gonna
need it because everybody gets mad at me
and they're not wrong of course you've
got to have a you know a great idea is a
great idea it's just there's so many of
those there's so many great ideas
there's way less great executions there
are the 7,000 greatest ideas of all time
never saw the day of life they just have
it because execution is hard and that
and that's the key and so yes ideas are
amazing and I'm sure your idea is
wonderful but I equally believe that
everybody's ideas are wonderful there's
a lot of great ideas that are wonderful
and that X I'm I've seen a hell of a lot
more people execute very below-average
ideas to build amazing lives there's
there's unlimited multi-million dollar
companies people have made millions of
dollars hundreds of thousands of dollars
had tremendous success in business on
executing an average idea notes an
average idea a social and digital agency
that's that's a below-average I
yeah it worked like it's it's good if
the labs ain't ready to have Tyler as an
employee so I think that uh I think
that's the key to that question Mike
asks what have you changed your mind
about in the last six months oh I saw
this come through
Goodwin India Mike what have I changed
my mind about in the last six months as
you could tell this is hard for me
because uh they're like changed my mind
about it's hard I think the only thing
that comes to mind is I will tell you
that I'm in constant motion with
vaynermedia around culture around skill
around offerings around people I've
changed my mind on people both pro and
con
but there hasn't been anything massively
philosophical I stay pretty consistent
with my 7 10 15 key pillars I'll tell
you you know I'll say that yeah there's
nothing there's nothing really so
unbelievable other than when you're the
CEO of a company you're slightly pulling
levers at all times and as some of you
could say you're changing your idea
again around strategies around
opportunities publishing you know
building out the Vayner publishing stuff
I've changed a lot of different
strategies because the markets moving
virtual reality I'm way more into it
than I was that could be a change of an
idea it's more of an acceleration of
idea
there's been no hard like oh I believe
that actually this is an interesting
time to open this up I mean lying if I
didn't say this maybe it's cuz my 40th
birthday is coming in two days
I am secretly for the first time in my
life thought about the notion of in the
next decade taking an entire year off
and not working at all yeah that's
that's a bomb right that's a real that's
a bomb but we'll see we'll see but you
know what I've consistently been where
there's smoke there's fire kind of guy
and I don't mean like shut down from
social and like weird stuff I mean like
just I don't know move the family to
like Sydney Australia and let the kids
spend the year there and just like Zen
it out and like get real real buff and I
want to I want to stretch more than any
way an official official Jets prediction
the New York Jets are very hurt we're on
our fourth safety fourth safety the
buffalo bills are getting healthy the
Jets won by five points against the Jags
seem that hadn't won a road game in 12
games after they won two turnover battle
for two zero four to zero they won by
five points
I think Buffalo is getting healthier I
think we're extremely banged up we we
lost our one of our guards for the year
our center Nick Mangold is banged up all
of our receivers are banged up our
quarterbacks lumps banged up we are a
one banged up banged up team
I see disaster for my New York Jets
tonight and I mean it crushes me to say
this but I think we get pretty handled I
think we get blown out I actually really
do which just sucks but I think the Jets
lose tonight 29 to 10
yeah
yeah
you keep asking all the question of the
day cuz I'll bring that back question of
the day since that really just hurt my
feelings
what's the last thing that you've had to
say out loud that really disappointed
you you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
actually you know what I'm gonna fix my
prediction I just thought about it a
little bit more I think ships are gonna
score a little more than I think I'm
changing it first time first time change
I'm going
31:16 Buffalo thanks
what's that thank you
oh you are awesome what's your name hi
Ali nice to meet nice to meet you thanks
for watching my favorite sauce to the
holidays yes it's really cool I said
that people are but I said a couple
things I said one it's amazing to have a
business where people give a [ __ ] about
that
and two it's funny to me that so many my
friends that love apples simplicity are
mad about the simplicity of this cup so
I just talked about people complaining
you know I saw that oh yeah thanks
nicely to take care
[Music]